nous sommes mieux avec matteo
ghisalberti rédacteur en chef du média
putsch
[Musique]
bonsoir matteo ghisalberti merci
beaucoup d'être avec tout sur rt france
alors on a vu en ces manifestations en
allemagne effectivement vous il ya eu du
monde - en france mais l'italie aussi
s'y met et manifestent contre les
mesures prises pour protéger
a priori les italiens oui il ya beaucoup
de contradictions dans la façon où il a
été appliqué cette mesure qui était très
respectée parra les italiens il faut
dire surtout dans les régions où il ya
eu ce moment c'est qu'apax un peu de
lombardie et mais un peu comme en france
il ya des contradictions parce que
simple au début de la pandémie quand le
président de la région lombardie
ratinaud fontana avait été filmée lors
d'un duplex avec le mas et on l'avait
traité des chacals on lui avait dit que
en fait on avait accusé de faire vouloir
faire de la politique sur un exploitant
de virus la peur est maintenant
finalement on a un peu l'impression que
c'est le gouvernement qui fait le
discours a le même discours ou maintenir
la peur c'est ça l'accusation principale
que non seulement les mouvements
d'extrême droite il faut dire qu'à
organiser aussi cette manifestation mais
aussi il y avait des comités de
l'association internationale des
associations des protections de mineurs
qui conteste la mesure des masses il
craint que sur tous les enfants puissent
avoir des séquelles aussi psychologique
parce que ce qu'ils disent c'est que les
enfants vont être habitué à ne plus
avoir des relations interpersonnelles
mais à être de plus en plus des pardons
sur vos concerts vous dire ça des écrans
cesser ces mesures que qui sont
qualifiés de contradictoire par les
italiens pourtant elles sont efficaces a
priori puisqu'il ya dix fois moins de
deux cas avérés en tout cas en italie
qu'en france comment ça se fait selon
vous pour ce que j'ai pu voir un anneau
en italie cet été d'ailleurs j'ai
remarqué que le respect des du port de
masques et étaient en tout cas c'est
assez développé même dans les
restaurants par exemple il y avait aussi
la prise de la température à chaque fois
que comme que lyon se présenter à
l'entrée et puis par exemple aussi dans
les supermarchés on ira répartissez les
entrées de clients
quand il y avait trop de trop de monde
donc peut-être des mesures de ce type
ont contribué à limiter la diffusion du
virus
ce que je peux dire par contre c'est que
je vu l'application plus stricte dans
les régions qui avaient été les plus
touchés par le virus
ce printemps est un peu moins respectée
moins strictes dans d'autres régions ou
par contre ce qui est intéressant de
dire c'est que les italiens aussi on
fait un peu comme les français se sont
éteints respect dans leur pays et ils
sont quand même aller à la mer on a eu
des foyers qui se sont créés dans
certaines localités balnéaires ou
touristiques
mais pas dans les proportions française
et pour l'instant on trouve pas
d'explication particulière
oui et l'italie les carreaux parts un
petit peu à la hausse mais beaucoup
moins qu'en france effectivement l
italie a eu
sur le touriste aussi cet été comme la
france ou pas disons que l'italie aussi
à payer l'impôt à payer cher
l'immobilisation du monde touristique il
ya eu du tourisme national il est lu
quelques étrangers notamment français
parce que finalement l'italie était de
ce pays qui avait maintenu les les
frontières ouvertes terrestre avec avec
la france donc c'était plus facile de 10
arrivée il n'y avait pas des mesures
particulièrement contraignantes pour
aller quarantaine
si vous permettre mais permettez par
contre il faut dire aussi une autre
chose or où les contestations qui lie à
lui aujourd'hui armé qu'il ya il ne faut
pas oublier que les italiens ne comprend
plus pourquoi ils devraient porter le
masque est restée des amendes alors que
par exemple il ya un problème qui est
désormais sous les yeux de tout le monde
de l'e de l'arrivée des migrants qui
souvent celui des centres d'accueil et
qui ont provoqué par exemple la réaction
du président de la région fille et mère
qui a voulu fermer ses ailes passion et
les foyers de copies de secret l'année
où se trouvaient ses centres d'accueil
et donc ils protestent contre cette
menace potentielle de contamination de
deux de ces personnes sont des
disparités de traitement qui mes parents
car son le ratio n'est pas le match ou
pourquoi parce que les personnes
migrantes qui arrive à willis ont invité
naturellement à respecter les mesures de
distance et sans social mais on sait
déjà combien avec les moyennes
si on veut continuer à opérer donc avec
des bateaux de beauce qui pourrait
sembler où la promiscuité est très
importante et ce n'est pas leur faute
d'être parfois aussi malade de comics
mais il ya eu plusieurs cas des fuites
de la part de ces migrants qui refusait
de rester dans les centres d'accueil et
qui donc potentiellement continuer à en
partie la hausse de nombre de
contaminations merci beaucoup météo mise
alberti seront dus à nos questions sur
arte france merci